[Music]
you talk about your humble beginnings
growing up and they were they were and
you grew up in Cleveland
well chagrin falls outside of Cleveland
listen to that applause yeah watch this
if you think that's good Bowling Green
State University oh you're all out of
work yeah they're all liars humble
beginnings was it not a lot of money in
your family was Christmas a hard hard
for you growing up they didn't tell me
about Christmas until I was 17 so I
thought though why do we keep bringing
this tree and yeah but no my folks my
dad took care of horses mm-hmm so he had
a pitchfork and you know that kind of
taken care of any trained racehorses
so I was originally started out to be a
jockey really you were a jockey yeah at
this week even the horses ask you to get
off yeah so when did you when did you
decide show business did your parents
know did they understands that you
wanted that show business was in your
blood that you wanted to be a comedian
it pretty much parallels the racing
business you know because you bet on the
fact that you're gonna make it and as
you know well you know you know so
[Laughter]
you know the heartbreak I sure do
we all know the heartbreak Tim I have to
ask you about something I as you know
and we've talked about this before I
like many people my age and and
continuing because all of this lives on
on the internet thank god this is heaven
ending no this is all ok
the year was 1933 Babe Ruth approached
me with loud yeah my point was that I
grew up watching you and God you would
make me laugh on the cow Burnett I'm
sorry to hear that
that's ok and ruined my chance
rocky and I watched you and I remembered
there was one sketch in particular that
I've always wanted to talk to you about
which is a dentist sketch was absolutely
hilarious where you're with Harvey
Korman man it looks like Harvey Korman
has completely lost control he did it
you actually wet his pants so wet his
pants
yes laughing he let me out well I'll be
sad and it wasn't laughs if there was no
reason why he wet his pants yeah you got
him laughing so hard in the sketch that
he he wet himself yes and I'm very proud
of that too because I own the cleaners
at the time
it was a good side business wasn't here
oh god yes yeah it was about a guy who
was a dentist and he accidentally poked
himself in the hand with novocaine and
immobilized his hand this was based on
something that really you would win in
the army yeah a guy he said we're gonna
pull his tooth and so he took my look
like this
he stuck the needle in and it went
through my cheek and into his thumb and
so he put all the novocaine in there and
he's going now whoa so I said you okay
and he said yeah are just this will be
coming around soon and so he said we're
gonna pour out now and I said no you're
not yeah
so I spent an extra two weeks in the
army because of not listening to this
lieutenant who was gonna wanted to pull
my tooth with it without the use of his
hand without the use of his hands just
his feet yeah we actually have this clip
you're making harvey korman laughing are
we gonna see him wet himself on camera
well if you look real close ha ha yeah
he did let's watch for this historic
television moment
[Music]
[Music]
I'll be right with you
this pastor too dark